ahora que te algunas tardes comenzó a
las nueve de la mañana de argentina
simultáneamente en todo el país cada
jurisdicción lo organizó a su manera con
las dosis que recibió del gobierno
nacional que las adquirió a través de un
acuerdo con el fondo de financiamiento
ruso que se encarga de la distribución y
la entrega de estas vacunas llegaron
como bien indicaba es unas primeras
primeras 300.000 dosis que se están
dando en forma prioritaria el personal
de salud luego a lo largo de enero y
febrero se espera la llegada de millones
de dosis más para completar la segunda
vacunación que se le debe dar son 22
dosis por persona vacunada a estas
personas y sumar nuevas personas que
deban ser vacunadas no está exento de
polémica el hecho del uso de esta vacuna
por varios motivos pero sobre todo
porque hay quienes cuestionan que se
está vacunando antes de que haya
publicados en revistas con refiera todos
los resultados de la fase 3 de las
pruebas de esta vacuna pero bueno es
parte de la discusión sin embargo el
gobierno considera que es un éxito haber
empezado a vacunar a la población con
con la vacuna es public be en el
contexto de esta pandemia aquí en
argentina